now charity is warning that public
health could be at risk because GP
surgeries are refusing to register
asylum seekers doctors of the world says
almost forty percent of patients it's
tried to register have been turned away
let's talk to dr. Emma Preston a
volunteer GP at Bethnal Green doctors of
the world clinic good morning good
morning what is the reason and that
people are being turned away well I
think it's mainly to do with lack
knowledge about amongst frontline staff
and in the fact that all people are
entitled to primary care regardless of
whether you have documents or or a
passport or anything else like that or
proof of address so it's purely it just
needs to be more awareness amongst
frontline staff and receptionist and GP
surgeries and that anyone's entitled to
primary care do we need to view this not
only as an issue for these particular
people which clearly it is but in terms
of wider public health if people aren't
getting the medical assistance they need
well I think let's just be clear it's
not just refugees it's anybody without
proof of address so for example homeless
people various vulnerable adults and
society and public health is obviously
one one thing to think about it's also
people's personal health as well so
essentially it is just a problem with
with paperwork and it's that not being
processed or not being available exactly
as it should be yes exactly I mean that
there is perhaps the perception with
these sort of figures that that some
surgeries are not wanting to take on
people where they perceive there could
be you know ongoing health issues or
putting extra strain and already under
strain practice is there any evidence to
suggest that it is happening no there's
not evidence on that front as I say it
is purely and to do with paperwork lack
of addresses and passports being a
barrier to people being able to register
with GP surgeries when they shouldn't be
but people who find themselves in there
position for whatever reason what can
they do to access health care and so I
think I mean they can access a
mainstream GP surgery it's just that GP
surgeries need to realize that these
people can register and they don't need
a proof of address and passport but if
they're being turned away what do they
do yeah so um well I work for a charity
called doctors of the world and and and
we assist people who have been out to
register at mainline surgeries and then
try and you know provide them with the
care they need and unfortunately some
people may may access any or
inappropriate services if they weren't
able to register with the GP so I think
it just highlights you know we all need
to work together to make sure frontline
staff and GP surgeries are made aware
that anybody should be able to access
primary care in you're working at
Bethnal Green in East London I mean is
that an area where you're seeing
actually a lot of strain a lot of
pressure on what is a volunteer service
and yes I mean it's a busy clinic and
you know obviously primary care in
general is under a lot of strain and
pressures as we as we know and so it's
not just within this clinic it's
generally within primary care and if
somebody is boxed into a corner and they
are desperate they could contact doctors
of the world exactly yes exactly and
with ridah system and our priority is
you know obviously treating patients but
also registering them with main main
line gp7 services dr. pressing thank you
for being here this morning pleasure
thank you